Peter Svidler the Russian commentator
but for those of you who don't speak
Russian he's with us at today's he gives
us some insights from the booth speak
English Pete please Peter certainly
Peter speaks fine English and he comes
up with some words you say what you know
that word so definitely digging into the
Webster unabridged version for some of
your turns
but Peter thank you so much Peter
Svidler which I mentioned of course is a
time Russian champion those are some
serious gangsters in those tournaments
it's a win at eight times it's simply
unbelievable Peter you're doing the
Russian language commentaries we really
appreciate that you must be thrilled
that these games today yeah this round
once again there's this narrative that
people play particularly freely before
the rest day and I have a feeling that
what what chess coverage once again I'm
not answering the question you asked but
because this coverage is unarguably I
think the best in the world
one thing the chess is maybe somewhat
lacking is more more in-depth stats and
I was very much like working on it yeah
I know we've had this discussion affair
many times already even during this
year's coverage and one thing that would
be very very interesting to know is
actually what happens to percentages of
decisive results before and after red
states and right at the top of the show
we did have that we had that about after
the rest days and at this event oh the
last three years of this event and we
had three wins and and here it is on the
screen three wins in 2015 three decisive
Game three decisive games in 2016 last
year only one decisive game but two of
them went to the second time control and
one of them
Magnus play 294 moves against Nakamura
so certainly fighting chess in the
second half no I mean this tournament
generally future is fighting chest but
the percent the percentage of deciders
is interesting and today is a fantastic
round I mean once again these are you
know players of very very serious
strength and very equal strength so they
could steal these games could still end
in a draw but so far I really enjoy what
I'm seeing on all five boards and could
be a very very interesting day
in particular I don't know which game
you chose but we are covering the the
Grisha Carlson game I mean you obviously
are covering I mean we're all covering
all games but I'm in which I don't know
we really like this one a lot yeah we
chose this as a game of the run before
they started and we are not just being
being let down there and what's your
assessment look at this position it's
chaotic he's got a knight on a one a
knight on g4 hand he just gave up his
Danko bishop well he was he wasn't going
to have to anyway so he I think he does
this in order to bring the knight back
to f6 I think the point is compared to
some of the lines we were discussing
where blade goes ninety five instead of
Bishop takes c3 he wants to have at
least one light piece on the Kings side
to safeguard the King because he will
have to pay some attention to the Queen
side for a while and there were some
lines where white actually started a
very serious attack on the King side if
you trade everything off so after BC
three I expect he will go Knight f6 and
keep this knight on f6 as a kind of
stabilizing influence but I think he
might be in trouble I think and what
really surprised me and I have an
explanation for it but once again as any
outsider explanation it could be
completely wrong but I have a feeling
that he either just flat-out missed or
seriously miss assess the idea of g3 g4
and it threw him because the the Knight
takes d4 is fine but spending something
like two or three minutes on Knight
takes a 1 when Bishop takes e4 was
definitely a move that needed assessing
at least and arguably was maybe even
stronger than that takes a 1 frankly and
like on air we just started discussing
should take c4 and all the possibilities
it opened up and then he just took one
a1 and I think for for Magnus to play
this fast in a position of this
complicatedness I don't speak black city
yeah I don't speak this language
obviously I think you knew the word
complexity I think it speaks to a degree
of shock because it's very very unusual
for me
not to not to consider his options quite
carefully in position in a position is
difficult and also in a game that's
important so that would have come as a
shock to you yeah yeah no I I fully
understand the shock part but at this
point you you know as you know a Russian
schoolboy you know this is a very very
nice stroke which I like I like using
now and then yeah every right every
Russian school boy gets thought that you
just sit on your hands for a while right
you just don't allow yourself to make a
move if if it's not a normal illegal
move in the position you just have to
come down and reassess and I have a
feeling that this has not been done
after often g-49 344 and it may have
cost him because the the current
position they have I think is favored
for white I don't know how much but III
feel it's quite having a favor for white
right now any other positions I have
your attention I was looking at the game
between Wesley and Anand this year a
little bit yeah but once again in terms
of like optics the one that draws you I
immediately is gonna come over our onion
game because yeah you know voluntary
tripling up of the e pawns is not
something you see every day but once
again it feels like Hikaru
in his you have to assume homework
assessment of this has looked at this
deeper than LaVon because I the one did
not look surprised so you you get the
impression that he also looked at this
precise precise move order and decided
it's perfectly safe of like but the
current position they have on the board
I think is safe and quite signal I mean
there is an edge for white it might not
be enough to win but I like White's
position now so it's so it's an
interesting idea about he karo whole
what's it been like doing commentary for
the Sinquefield Cup in Russian you
played here in the last couple of years
yourself and now you need to watch your
colleagues playing and talking about it
in Russian yeah it's I try figuring out
when was the last time I did any kind of
serious commentary in Russian and came
up with the answer 2012 so it has been a
while since I've since I've done this
but it's very very enjoyable I really
like working with Mir
he's a good good good friend and a very
very good commentator of his own right
and also I just enjoy st. Louis and like
a nod has to be has to be made today is
an opening ceremony of the Russian Super
Final tomorrow is the first round and
this will be the first time in 15 years
and I'm not playing in the tournament
and I can say this with with certainty
that this is just about the only place
on earth that could make me you know
considering of playing in the Russians
to the Russian Super finals so I just
love coming here and this is a you know
a great team of people to work with and
we absolutely appreciate appreciate
having you as a teammate you are gonna
play though and play quite soon in the
champion showdown you get the Cara
Nakamura in just 960 and we're gonna
also have Garry Kasparov in the building
as well some really delightful matchups
what is your thought about playing in
this event in just about a couple of
weeks I was extremely happy when I got
this invite because I haven't played 960
competitively or otherwise frankly since
I lost that final match against the one
Aronian I used to be I mean the the
title obviously comes with with an
asterisks there but I was four-time
world champion in 960 between I think Oh
two in those six I played those matches
and minds because Hans Walter Schmidt
was a huge you know he was a pioneer of
trying to promote 960 and create
world-class events inside in 1960 but
then I lost to live on who is also a
giant of the game and and then the match
is kind of petered out because I think
in general the sponsorship for the -
events disappeared over time and the
events themselves just just disappeared
off the map which was very sad because
they were fantastically well organized
and I've been missing the game I really
like the game and the chance to play it
in this setting against an opponent like
Hikaru who I mean I started a dog I have
no no illusions about that Hikaru has
more recent practice in the game
he is generally you know sort of more
much food than I am these days but I'm
working really hard
you're like number 14 in the world come
on I'm working really hard here so
sitting setting this up and your Russian
champion but still like I thought it was
a fantastic opportunity and I was very
very happy to to accept and should be
should be a fantastic event well we're
gonna look forward to copping your games
you're calling these games you will you
will you will have some some who's and
us there and not not all of them
positive there's light hanging you got
it so good not too many night saying
thank you so much sure one of the great
shining nights of our game Peter Svidler
and well they said let you get back to
work so the Russian fans can enjoy your
coming